so there's really two rules for building
fluid layouts use percentages or
viewport units something little size as
you resize the window and then test
while you're resizing the window let's
take a look at how this worked out on
the mobile device we went from this
layout without any changes to my blog to
this layout definitely an improvement I
don't have to scroll left to right to
see everything on the screen and you may
notice the font size is actually a bit
larger now the font size was always set
in M units although it's actually still
a bit small for a mobile device so we
should probably bump that up let's take
a look on the tablet in the tablet
layout we went from this layout to this
again a definite improvement this is
actually a pretty readable experience
and even when we rotate the screen we
end up with a nice reformatting all this
is really just a long-winded way of
saying be sure to create fluid layouts
be sure to reflow to use all the space
on the screen and take advantage of
every bit you can and be sure you adapt
to different screens as well one tool
that makes reflow a lot easier
particularly across very different
screen sizes is the new flex box layout
in CSS this new tool lets you stack
elements in flexible rows or columns